making it big on twitch these days
doesn't just
happen overnight some streamers are
known for their personality
or their calm demeanor while others have
built a brand
by being just straight up insane
oh my god but regardless of how they do
it
every streamer has one ultimate goal
and that goal is to build a community a
place where
fans can return to get the content that
they know and love
because without viewers finding and
maintaining success
on twitch can be nearly impossible
happy birthday you piece of [ __ ] i love
you brother most streamers typically
start out playing specific
games for an audience that they know
will turn up to watch whenever they go
live
even if they can't stand the game
anymore this game is so stupid bro
like the community these little kids is
so dumb but there are those lucky few
who have been able to evolve and
unshackle themselves from the
constraints of a single game
streamers whose personalities are so big
that their fans will watch them do well
pretty much anything world's hottest
chocolate
three two one cheers
oh oh my god
but no content creator has managed to
combine their skills
in game with top tier memory quite like
timmy it's timmy on a variety streamer
who has taken his stream production to
the next
level while dumpstering his opponents
no matter what title he plays
so who exactly is timmy and what
inspired this ultra
talented head clicking savant to choose
memeing over the chance to compete for
silverware
just kidding
okay guys before we dive into timmy's
story be sure to
some smash that like button subscribe to
the channel
and turn on notifications that way you
won't miss any future episodes of
offbeat
and i promise that those ones will be
about counter-strike okay so before he
keck w
his way into our hearts what was this 21
year old
san francisco native doing with his life
well
although he was born in the bay area
young timmy
moved to texas at the age of five where
alongside his brother he cut his teeth
playing games like maplestory
and soldier front two that's like my
first shooter and i
really enjoyed it like i i honestly went
through like six laptops
just to play the game because like
literally you would get trojans it would
actually like
mess up your computer to the point where
you couldn't turn it on after a couple
of months playing
as timmy got older he found himself
being drawn to games of a more
competitive nature
and like many great gamers who came
before him
he too eventually made the mistake of
playing
league of legends like you guys know
that there are both official
and fan-made tutorials for dota right
like you don't only have to play the one
that riot made
even worse timmy wasn't just sampling
the game
he became a straight-up league junkie
and his addiction to it was
all-consuming and
actually prevented him from focusing on
pretty much anything else
especially school but after hitting a
wall at diamond
timmy's league bender thankfully came to
an end
right around the time he discovered
god's gift to the first person shooter
genre
cs go once again timmy dove head first
into his new found game of choice
i'm just so much better than that guy
i'm just so much better than all of you
okay he loved counter-strike and was
fully intent on reaching global elite
and when he wasn't grinding on the
server he could be found watching
streams
where a certain rowdy one left him
feeling inspired
when i was in school i was never able to
focus and like i was very like fidgety i
i was like always moving i had a lot of
energy
and like watching like this guy like
shroud you know i mean like he was so
good at video games
but it wasn't just like he was good he
was just like kind of like vibing he was
like
easily just like stomping everybody it
was just like amazing
and i just like damn like this guy's
just so cool
you know like i want to be him i want to
be this guy who can just
effortly just stomp everybody and
not even like like even care so in 2018
timmy tried his hand streaming battle
royales like pub g
and realm royale and although only a
handful of people were watching
he loved being on camera and sharing his
gameplay with others
by the end of his first year of college
timmy had dipped his toe into streaming
and reached his goal of hitting global
elite
that was the good news the bad news
is that it didn't come without a cost
around like the end of the semester
i wasn't doing too well uh on the second
semester i was like getting
like honesty c's and d's and even a
failing class like
30 or 40 grade and i was just saying i
just told my parents i was like
yeah i just don't think school is for me
now as you can imagine
i'm dropping out of college to play
counter-strike
isn't exactly a phrase that parents are
thrilled to hear
especially in n a so uh when timmy
suggested that he was going to become a
full-time streamer
it wasn't well received my dad's very
traditional
he kind of looked at me like i was crazy
like you can't be serious right now you
know i mean like
you're trying to tell me that you want
to be a gamer you know what i mean like
they play video games for this your life
like that's
so unrealistic you know and like i even
told him like i know it sounds
unrealistic i know that like
it's not like your typical like be a
software engineer or be a doctor or
stuff like that
but yeah my dad wanted me to
kind of like really like think about it
now despite his father's initial
objections
eventually timmy's family got behind his
pursuit and with their blessing
he committed to streaming full-time now
like all upstart streamers
in the beginning timmy wasn't exactly
being showered with views
but when apex legends released in early
2019
things began to change apex was the
perfect
game for town it combined the natural
sweatiness that you get from competitive
first-person shooters
with the signature breaks in action that
make battle royale streams
so enjoyable to watch apex wasn't just
an arena to pull off incredible
highlights but
one that wasn't so hectic that it
demanded timmy's
full attention at all times and let's
not just
gloss over the fact that this kid was a
monster at it
so
how does it feel to be better it feels
great
feels great okay yeah yeah i bet it does
that was so sick
he is absolutely horny i should watch
this i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna pull him to my nade and then
i suck i suck one he's dead he's dead
he's dead okay
though let's go
while timmy's highlights and natural
charisma were certainly helping him to
grow his audience
it was in august that year when a clip
of him surviving
certain death blew up on twitter that he
really began to make waves i guess i can
sell that i can sell that i can sell it
i can stall until my
capital comes up
your top three you're good dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
every single pro player and person into
the
apex scene solid they knew who i was and
that's when like it all started
not long after the clip made its way
around the apex community more eyes were
drawn to timmy's stream and
even big apex streamers like asu began
hosting him regularly and while it was
pretty obvious that timmy was
cracked at apex that wasn't
really what caught everyone's attention
no what really made him stand out
was the level of effort he put into the
production
of his strength
[Music]
i was expecting this guy to be on right
now like what up
so you can have that three
two one i learned that
when someone hosted you like that you
have five minutes maybe five minutes to
make these people like you or they'll
never come back to your stream
so i always just had like the funny
memes they do like two
two memes like a kw or like something
something random like the summit 1g
something really unique and they were
like whoa like this guy's production is
kind of sick you know and that was like
the fight i was like a five-minute
one-hit wonder i guess timmy's streaming
career was finally beginning to pick up
some
serious traction not only was he rubbing
shoulders with some of apex's biggest
stars but through his endeavor he was
eventually able to meet the man
who inspired him to chase his dream
because i was playing with ace
and he actually is like okay like we
need to play rank like let's find a
third
and mike was actually like still playing
apex at the time she's like oh let's get
straubs i was like
hold up i was like what now like this is
the first time i've ever met child
i didn't i didn't necessarily like be
like yo like mike i'm like a big fan you
know i mean like oh
[ __ ] you know but i'm sure like he
figured out like obviously by chat or
like other people telling him
but timmy wasn't the only one fanboying
in fact
in december of 2019 timmy had built
enough of a following that he was signed
by golden guardians
as a content creator and thanks to his
likable personality
and penchant for the dank timmy's
audience was willing to follow him
beyond apex to
basically whatever games he wanted to
play
[Music]
now of course timmy's stream had grown
exponentially since the early days
but for him that wasn't enough
he knew that he needed to do something
crazy in order to keep
growing so he decided to do something
that had quite literally
never been done before in february of
2021
timmy set out on a challenge to hit 10
000
damage in a solo game and although he
came up short in the end
he finished the match with a whopping
9069 damage
something that most people never would
have thought possible
this meant that he had set a world
record for the most damage
in a single solo game after that stream
timmy was averaging roughly 5 000
viewers
every night but that still wasn't enough
so he decided to set himself one more
challenge
he wanted to go from bronze to master
in a single stream i knew that like i
could get it
easily if i just got my 6kp and then
went to the zone and played it you know
like a normal person
but i didn't want that like i didn't
want to just like be like oh like i got
it you know that's cool right but then
everyone's like oh you kind of got in
like a lame way you were just like
sitting still like you know i didn't
want that you know i wanted to get like
these high kill games
so every single game like i'd be running
out i'd be pushing you know
i'd be taking fights and like i would
end my games with like
10 to 15 kills you know in these diamond
lobbies as it got like later and later
that that whole mindset definitely
changed i was like i can't do this
hitting for it i need to get off
after suffering a game crash when he was
only
one match off of master timmy went on a
bit of a losing streak
but in the end 33 hours later
he accomplished his goal
throughout this marathon of a stream
timmy gained about 3 300 subscribers and
his viewership peaked at
54 000. 000 soon after
he signed with loaded a talent agency
that represents some
pretty big names in streaming like we're
talking shroud
summit and courage timmy had finally
made it
and although he hasn't quite hit the
same level of success that shroud has
he's definitely on the right track which
is saying a lot
it's really cool because i went from the
big fan of shroud
always watching him every single day and
now actually being able to play games
with him and
honestly like be like his close friend i
never imagined
myself to be like friends with shroud
actually just be like that close with
him
it's such a i always say like inspiring
thing to take others
to be like to always chase your dreams i
guess because
um anything is possible but as surreal
as rolling with twitch a-listers might
be for timmy
it's not a fortune that he stumbled upon
by accident
the success he's enjoying is a product
of his tireless work ethic
positive attitude and dogged commitment
to chasing his dream
[Music]
and it's through all of those things
that he's been able to win the praise
of not only his fans but his family too
my dad he uh he watches like my streams
every single night
at his like chiropractic place he has
like the tvs for like whatever like the
news or like tv shows
he'll watch like my stream my mom leave
like late at night she'll have like
my stream up on like the tv and she'll
be watching as well so they're really
supportive now which is really great
as of right now timmy is showing no
signs of slowing down
but one thing is for sure regardless of
what game he ends up diving into next
you can expect him to keep on doing his
thing turning people into both
highlights and memes
one clip at a time
let's go let's go
jack james
go
[Music]
like you don't only have to play the one
that riot made
it's pretty funny pretty funny it's not
bad league of legends players are like
the coldplay fans of esports
it's par for the course buddy like you
you get what you signed up you know what
you signed up for
you know what you signed up for all
right if you're gonna play the baby game
then you gotta take [ __ ] for playing the
baby game
like i don't know what to say